- What's up everybody?
We're here with Jane Lynch.
Give it up.
(applause)
- Hello, hello.
- Our next guest is a singer,
actor, game show host, author,
entrepreneur, popcorn
enthusiast, and big brother
to a couple guys you
might know, Nick and Joe.
Give it up for Kevin Jonas, everybody.
(applause)
(upbeat music)
- Yeah.
- Hello, hello.
- It's great to see you again.
Have y'all met before?
- We have.
- Yeah, we have actually.
- Yes, we have.
- Oh, okay, right on.
- Fellow game show hosts.
- Exactly. It's kind of a camaraderie.
- [Kevin] Friday night dinners-
- Fraternity sort of thing. Yes.
(laughs)
- I wanna come.
Okay, so we're gonna, we're
gonna talk popcorn in a minute.
But first, you and your wife
have a new kids book coming out.
- Yes, we do.
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- Yeah, we're really excited. Thank you.
This is our second
installment of the book.
You know, "There's a Beach in my Bedroom."
You know, we're just, it's
all about disappointment
and understanding what it to
do when things have to change.
And in our life, with as much
as our life can change in a-
(snaps)
drop of a hat sometimes,
you're expecting to do one
thing and you have to shift.
And so this was kind of about that.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh. Pivoting.
- It's hard,
- As a parent, too.
- Woo woo.
- Lot of bribery.
- Yeah. I have a nine and six
year old, Alena and Valentina.
Hey, we're not doing this today.
(deep voice) But you promised.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- (deep voice) You said
I could have ice cream.
- [Kevin] Yes, exactly.
But yeah, that, that was before
18 candy bars that you had.
- Yeah, exactly. Thank you.
Well, among their many, many ventures
Kevin and his brothers
have a popcorn line.
It's incredible.
It's called Rob's Backstage Popcorn.
- [Kevin] Oh, I don't know-
- [Kelly] Last month-
- [Kevin] You may have your own version.
- I, I may have my
fantastic, incredible flavor.
- [Kevin] Ooh.
- Last month, Nick came by
to unveil actually, their newest flavor.
It's called, Kelly's Classic Barbecue.
It's amazing.
It's actually addictive.
I'm sorry and you're welcome.
You had a contest in connection
with the flavors released though,
so, it ended in a tie.
- It did.
It's incredible, isn't it?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Oh, we had two amazing players.
They, it was a, it was a filter.
You had to catch popcorn in your mouth
on, you know, on the, on the Instagrams.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Kevin] Look at that. Look
at us all playing there.
- [Kelly] On the 'gram. (laughs)
- [Kevin] Sadly, we ended in a tie.
So, what better way to do it
than have it come to life
and do it in real life.
- So we have the two
gentlemen in our audience
who tied for first.
So, let's say hello to
Josh and Cam, everybody,
(applause)
What's up, y'all?
- [Kevin] Hi Josh. Hi Cam.
- Do you mind doing this
contest first in tiebreaker?
Do you mind hosting?
- I am honored and I'm thrilled.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] Okay. Okay.
- Well, Josh and Cam
have spent days training
in the art of popcorn,
tossing, and catching.
Why don't, why don't y'all
come down here right now
Josh and Cam,
(audience applauds)
so we can get this tiebreaker started.
- Thank you, America.
Well, we've broken you into two teams
representing Rob's Backstage Popcorn.
Kevin and Cam are Team Sweet & Salty.
Woo. Let's hear for them.
(audience cheers)
Kelly and Josh are Team Barbecue.
- [Kelly] Yes! Yes!
(audience cheers)
- Now While Kelly and Kevin
are part of the competition
they have one role and one role only.
Moral support.
And that is it.
They cannot help their
teammates in any other way.
All right, Cam and Josh.
You will have 30 seconds
to catch as many kernels as you can.
One kernel at a time.
Your hand must go below your face
and the kernel must be tossed
above your head to count.
And if we tie again,
we'll go to Sudden Death.
All right.
Kelly and Kevin, you wanna
show them how it's done?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Kevin] Absolutely.
- I, I need redemption.
Here you go.
(everyone cheers and applauds)
- [Jane] Nice.
- Oh my god, it's so good.
- [Jane] Folks, there are official judges
from Rob's Backstage Popcorn
standing by to determine
the official winner.
All right, fellas, Cam and Josh.
Are you all set?
- We're ready.
- All right. Let's get
30 seconds on the clock.
- [Kelly] (claps) You're gonna do it.
- [Jane] Go!
(fast-paced music)
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] (shouts) You're amazing!
You're amazing!
He is crushing it!
You are killing it.
What the hell?
(Kelly screams)
(loud horn sounds)
- Oh my god.
- Wow!
- Oh my-
- Okay.
(drumroll plays)
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
- [Jane] Judges?
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- [Jane] Our official winner.
- Cam and Josh. You guys
really put your all into this.
And so of course,
we don't wanna let anyone
leave empty handed.
So, we're giving you, Josh, $5,000.
(cheers and whoops)
- [Kevin] Take that all day. That's right.
And Cam, say hello to your brand new car.
(upbeat tempo)
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
Thank you so much everybody.
Keep an eye out for
Kevin in the new season
of "Claim to Fame" later this year.
And catch Jane in "Party Down" on Starz
starting February 24th.
We'll be right back with what I'm liking.
That was incredible.